do you feel any sense of and i've heard
you talk about instagram filters so
there's kind of
that beat on the street with it but
growing up in the world i mean
you know there were painstaking measures
you took
to fall into this cookie cutter
silhouette
it's like we put ourselves we elected
to be in a business that has some really
screwed up values
at times but is there a sense of relief
in going yeah i'm not perfect i don't
fit the mold
and screw it i'm so sick of living
trying to pretend i do it actually was
killing me so in order to save myself
i'm going to tell you the truth and if
you can like me for that then great
yes you nailed it that like if that's
the perfect
like sound bite for my documentary and
why i put it out
was like exactly that was like i was
trying something
that didn't work for me now i'm doing
something that is working for me and
instead
of you know uh
instead of feeling judged by everyone
i'm just gonna say look your opinion
about me doesn't
matter to me i'm doing what i need to do
for myself
um and my wellness my well-being like
i'm putting myself first in front of my
career
and that's something i never did before
because i was so preoccupied trying to
be
the sexy feminine pop star
that i just like ignored
like who i am i don't know i cut my hair
because
i just wanted to free myself of all of
the
gender and sexuality norms that were
placed on me as
a you know christian in the south
um and when i cut my hair i felt so
liberated because
i wasn't i wasn't subscribing
to an ideal or a belief placed upon
me to be something that i'm not and now
that i'm owning who i am
like i feel the happiest i've ever felt
and and that's a that's that's because
i'm being honest
you know secrets keep you sick i've
heard that a million times and i and i
fully believe it
now there's nothing there's no secrets
for the world
to find out like i just put it out there
and i'm like hey this is
this is it this is me if you don't like
it fine
but if this provokes a conversation
and raises awareness takes away the
stigma about the topics i'm talking
about
then that's what i want is to just open
people's perspectives and to change the
conversation around recovery too
when you talk about secrets something
that really touched me personally
and the documentary was at a certain
point in my life when i did start
kind of getting overconfident about
where i was at with like my drinking and
things
i did start to hide things from people
and i noticed you were really good at
hiding things from people
like they would say they don't know like
they didn't know and you're like but you
were even there that night you were
there that day how did you not know
and i was curious thank god
like i have some friends
who although i thought i was good at
hiding things they are
extremely tough love oriented people
and in a lot of the ways they were good
karmatic compensation for all the
hollywood people who did not
put you in your place indulged gave you
access and never would say a thing
because
god forbid they got cut out of your
orbit some of my
best best friends are people you know
they're not
in the industry and yeah um
and it's really fun because i they are
so
down to earth so chill that um i find
myself gravitating towards them over
other industry people because yeah um
because my friend like i came home one
day i'd done like
interview i'm living with one of my best
friends and uh
so fun yeah totally i was just
in a like i was engaged to a
dude and almost did that and
i was like that's not the life for me
like i want to have fun
and i want to live with my friends like
let's normalize that
you know and so anyways i i just if i
didn't have two children
i would actually ask you if you wanted
to be roommates because
wow i'd say yes in a heartbeat some of
my happiest moments in my
life are without question and i moved
out on my own when i was 14. so i banked
a lot of years
with roommates my girlfriends it is some
of the happiest times of my life is
living with my friends i wouldn't be
surprised
or i invite all of them to like go back
to it at some point like should we not
just all
end up in a happy commune anyway yeah
definitely she so i was i came home one
day after doing like interviews
and photo shoots and whatnot and she was
like hey demi
so you've been doing rock stars all day
you want to do some normal i was like
yes that's what i want and
then we put on grey's anatomy and the
walking dead and it was
it was over from there that is good
absolutely
you